you know i used to see left-wing
protests and demonstrations as mere
annoyances you know events to be
dismissed and ignored basically but now
i see them as well still events to be
dismissed in a lot of ways but also as
opportunities and with feminists across
the country gathering together on
saturday for another women's march in
response to the impending end of row we
decided it'd be a perfect time to um
finally unveil the full trailer and
official premiere date for my upcoming
film what is a woman after all you know
i know from filming the documentary that
the women at the women's march are the
most confused of all about what a woman
actually is so uh this film should be of
great interest to them and very useful
to them
you know all that time spend all the
time at the women's march you think you
want to figure out what a woman actually
is so figured this would be a good way
to tell them that's why we thought they
would appreciate it if we hijacked their
event to promote the film and as it
turns out
they didn't appreciate it very much but
i still had fun and that's really what
counts so for the women's march in dc we
set up these mobile billboards on the
back of trucks we had them circle the
march all day long
and the billboards asked a pertinent
question which is if you can't define
what a woman is how can you have a
women's march
good question and then of course we
provided the url what is the woman.com
to uh where you could see the whole
trailer and become a member of the daily
wire i doubt we gained very many
subscribers from the dc women's march
but at least we gave them a question
that they could ponder and the same in
new york city where jeremy was nice
enough to let me use his jeremy's razors
billboard to pose the same question to
all of times square there was a women's
march in new york as well and there was
the la women's march where we took
things perhaps a step or two
farther by posing the ultimate question
what is a woman
to the entire la women's march all at
once via message in the sky so a sky
writer wrote the question in the sky
over top the city while another plane
carrying a banner with what is woman
woman.com circled around all day
now the funniest thing about this was um
the reaction from la residents who had
no context at all and perhaps didn't
even know
that a women's march was happening and
yet emerged from their homes on saturday
morning to find this question
emblazoned across the heavens as if god
himself was prompting them to think
about it i should also mention that the
hashtag
what is a woman was trending on twitter
moving up the trending charts quickly
threatening to overtake all of the
women's march hashtags
until i posted the picture of the sky
writing at which point the hashtag
disappeared from twitter's trending
topics all at once
just like that never returned
apparently i think it maybe it was a
bridge too far for the folks at twitter
many of them who live in that area and i
guess decided we were simply having
too much fun
and we were
but trolling aside the important point i
think is the film which
again will officially premiere we can
finally announce on june 1st
you may remember that we originally said
it would premiere in may
but that was before we remembered that
june is pride month
and we simply could not pass up the
opportunity to unveil the trailer during
the women's march
and then premiere the film on the first
day of pride month
just the symmetry there it's it's it's
poetry it's poetic i think
the way things work work out that way
now if you think we went literally above
and beyond for the women's march you
just gotta wait and see what we have in
store for pride month
and the first thing we have in store is
the movie itself of course and for just
a small taste of what the film is all
about i'm gonna play the full trailer
for you right now
if you're listening to the audio podcast
uh and you want to see the visuals that
go with this and trust me you definitely
do want to see the visuals
then you can go to my youtube channel or
whatiswoman.com after the show and check
it out but for now
uh here's a trailer let's watch
[Music]
what is a woman
can you tell me that
[Music]
well you're at the women's march you
must have some idea please if one person
could tell me what a woman is you are
not here for women we ask you to leave
what is that
i'm a husband i'm a father of four i
host a talk show i give speeches i write
books i like to make sense of things a
woman is not anything in particular
there is not one particular thing it
could be many things to many people some
women have penises right some men have
vaginas i like scented candles i've
watched sex in the city yeah how do i
know if i'm a woman that's a great
question you're not a scientist you're
not a gender studies major no how do you
know that you're a man i guess because i
got a dick
can a man become a woman
i'm not a woman so i i can't really
answer that women only know what women
are are you a cat no can you tell me
what a cat is
you want to tell us what a woman is
i'm a biological woman that medically
transitioned to appear like a male i
will never
be a man and so they go on the internet
and they're told that all their problems
will be solved if they become a man so
you worry that there could be a sort of
social contagion element of this a teeny
tiny bit maybe it got me at 42
your child doesn't have a chance
and you're affirming it with hormones
that have never been used in this way
puberty blockers which are completely
reversible completely reversible one of
the drugs used is lupron right which
has actually been used to chemically
castrate sex events
you know what i'm not sure that we
should continue with this interview you
don't want to talk about the drugs that
you give to kids or
how can they be removing the healthy
breasts of 15 year old girls there are
masculine girls there are feminine boys
what are we going to do about that carve
them up how can this whole thing be
happening matt
i wanted us to have a safe place to be
able to talk about this part of me wants
to ask why you care so much i care about
the truth i care about children i care
about the women who are having their
opportunities stolen from them is it
transphobic to tell the truth the
interview's over let's turn off the
cameras excuse me they're fair i just
wanted to know what is a woman and
you're not going to find out based on
what i'm saying would you ever want to
move to america
they say
no
never
[Music]
i hope you enjoyed it a little bit
we'll see when it comes out
yes you will you will um june first
again is the premiere date if you have
been if you've been putting off becoming
a daily wire
member and procrastinating then what i
would say is that uh now is the time
and if you if you think about it all if
you have it in your budget become a
daily wire member or maybe get rid of
one of the 15 other streaming services
that you don't need and have nothing but
crap and uh go sign up for the daily
wire go to what is woman.com right now
and sign up or wait for that till after
the show and then sign up you know one
of the worst things about trailers is
that so often they spoil the film
because they show you all the best parts
and you see the trailer and you're like
this looks good and you go watch the
movie and you think well i already saw
the this is
the best part of the movie i already saw
that's not the case with this trailer
because the best parts and by that i
mean the most outrageous
shocking hilarious disturbing sometimes
all those things at once parts are being
saved for the film i can assure you of
that what you saw there is just sort of
the tip of the gender confused iceberg
and hopefully it's enough for you to see
that though we're doing a lot of fun
trolling to promote the film
what is a woman is not itself
merely an exercise in trolling i mean
there's some of that because it's me and
i can't help myself but the titular
question is just the beginning of the
journey it's the door into the gender
ideology rabbit hole and we dive into
that rabbit hole and trace it all the
way to the bottom we stare into the
abyss and the abyss stares back
now i can tell you just from filming it
that
you know there are plenty of moments
when i had to stop myself from bursting
out laughing but also plenty of days
when we wrapped filming and i had
trouble sleeping at night because i felt
so unsettled by the things that we'd
seen the conversations we had the things
that we learned
uh there were a couple of times in
particular when
we talked about this when we were done
filming on these days it like felt like
we were
you know glaring directly into hell or
something because in a way we were
now my hope then for the film is that
it will rip open the
curtain and reveal gender ideology for
was it what it is uh this is a movement
that has gripped hold of our culture
largely by deception threat and force
certainly not by making compelling
arguments
and convincing people
so case in point i have hear the results
of a new poll from mclaughlin and
associates and summit.org
and this shows just how unconvinced most
people are
so listen to some of these numbers
in response to the question
do you believe it's possible to
distinguish between men and women
and of course we mean like physically
of those who gave a response 93 said yes
of course gender ideology tells you no
you can't you cannot there's nothing
physical about someone that would tell
you anything about um whether they're a
man or a woman
93 percent disagree with that claim by
gender ideology
93 percent
when asked about their personal feelings
about transgenderism only 36 percent
said that it's a healthy human condition
the rest said that it's unhealthy
though this is important
only half of those who said it's
unhealthy said they'd be willing to
speak up and say so the rest said that
they
keep quiet about it
when asked if elementary schools should
teach about sexual identity and sexual
behavior
28 said it was appropriate
42 said it was inappropriate
30 said not only inappropriate but
dangerous so that's 72 percent opposed
in all
and then should minors undergo gender
alteration procedures
90 percent against
now
there are still more people on the
incorrect side of these issues than
there ought to be because there ought to
be zero
but this makes it clear that the gender
ideologues are in a small tiny minority
they have convinced basically no one
yeah that's that's another interesting
question that maybe we could do in a
follow-up poll
which is like whatever your opinion of
this right now
have you changed it over the last five
years
i'd say they've convinced no one because
all the people who's you know the
whatever seven percent who said that oh
you can't tell the difference between
men and women
um
most of them
these are the people making the claim
these are the actual gender ideologues
so it's not like they've been convinced
they haven't convinced anyone of the
rightness of their claims i guess i
should say
they have however convinced lots of
people to be silent
they've convinced quote unquote lots of
people to just sort of cooperate and go
along
and that's why i'm hoping that our film
what is a woman
will not only expose the total absurdity
of gender ideology but also give people
the motivation
the inspiration
to take a stand against it
publicly
and unapologetically
finally
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated